As many of you know, we were on vacation last
week.
I'll have lots of stories for you from the
vacation on the bonus show today.
Some, some really good ones that I think you'll
like.
I did everything I could to disconnect from
the work, uh, things during, uh, to disconnect
from work.
Basically, during the break, one of the things
I came back to were more than a dozen bogus
copyright claims against our YouTube channel
from huge corporate legacy media outlets.
Now, some of you may remember that we dealt
with this during the presidential debates.
We would do live commentary of a debate.
The debate, maybe it was on CNN and CNN would
shut it down.
They would file a copyright claim and then
it was sort of like a debate.
Is it fair use?
Is it not?
Okay, that's not what I came back to.
What I came back to.
Our straight up bogus copyright claims.
When we've not used any content from the claimant,
it's always a huge corporate media outlet
and YouTube is straight up ignoring us, which
I'm going to get to in a moment.
This is how they will destroy independent
media.
Take a look at this.
This is my inbox.
This is partial.
This is about a dozen of them.
There are more on videos ranging from house
intelligence committee hearings, house judiciary
Hill hearings.
Simply house video of the house debating impeachment
for 12 hours.
We spent all day on multiple days producing
these streams using public domain video from
the house of representatives, not copywritten
video and then incomes, corporate media and
just claims the video.
Here's one specifically live Trump and peach
mint hearing number five.
Gordon Sunland received a third party claim
from associated press UK.
Another example from Univision and there were
many from Univision.
This was for Trump impeachment hearing day
three when it was uh, Alexander Veneman and
Jennifer Williams.
This one from Univision, I won't put them
all up on this on the screen.
I think you get the idea.
NBC, Univision associated press, CNN on and
on and on.
Since the hearings have started, I would estimate
that we've received 20 to 25 bogus, completely
bogus copyright claims from legacy corporate
media outlets whose content we have not used.
I have been told by people in my audience
that attorney Leonard French also received
a bunch from Univision and that he's taking
legal action.
I have reached out to Leonard and we're scheduled
to speak at the end of this week or early
next.
Now let's think through the next step.
Okay.
Because YouTube does have a process for disputing
these claims.
The way it's supposed to work is once you
say, no, I don't agree with this claim, I'm
going to dispute it.
All of the money that's earned from that point
forward is held in escrow and once the claim
is adjudicated, the money money is given to
whoever has the rights to the video, but it's
not so simple because number one, the escrow
period only starts when I filed the dispute.
We were away all of week.
These are videos still getting a numerous
views.
We're a full week goes by before I got home
and filed the dispute that money's gone no
matter what happens.
Number two, YouTube is not really adjudicating
the dispute.
When I file a dispute, CNN or Univision or
whoever gets 30 days to say, you know what,
David was right or no, we don't think David
was right and after that, I don't know that
there is any further recourse that I have.
If they say we're keeping the dispute going,
they can simply say David's wrong and they
keep the money.
Now, many of you might be wondering, but David,
your, your channel has almost 800,000 subscribers.
You're like in the top half of 1% of YouTube.
You must have a contact that YouTube, right?
I do.
I have a YouTube rep who I've been emailing
for months about this.
The YouTube rep typically responds with a
conversation with a combination of I'm away
auto responses saying I'm looking into this
and I'll follow up.
And of course there was no followup or simply
ignoring my emails or saying, you are actually
going to be getting a new YouTube rep.
But then I never am put in touch with the
new YouTube rep.
The system is broken.
The system is crushing us merely by making
me have to deal with this.
This is a common tactic.
Uh, when you get a law firm representing a
large corporation and they're what they want
to go after a small business or an individual,
one of the ways that they gum up the system
is sending endless discovery requests, requests
for documents, filing, uh, all sorts of different
motions that the small business or the individual
either become overwhelmed with by having to
fight or can't afford the legal fees required
in order to do it so that they are completely
taken out of actually running their business.
And that is the equivalent of what is going
on here.
And this is going to get worse in 2020 with
more and more political coverage across corporate
media.
And I don't know what we can do.
Certainly the solution is to be less reliant
on YouTube revenue at all.
And that's fine.
Which is why I say, you know, get a membership.
It's cheap.
I won't spend a lot of time on it.
David pakman.com/membership just sign up.
Take the big discount we have through the
end of the year last 2019 if you want, throw
us a dollar or two a month on Patrion at patrion.com/david
Pakman show, but this is bigger than just
moving support from YouTube ad revenue to
individual support.
Something needs to be done here, right?
We don't seem to be able to fight this in
any serious way because the system is skewed
towards huge corporate media outlets, often
algorithmically filing claims, which then
puts the onus on me to go and fight them instead
of creating content.
So I'm going to speak to a Leonard French
about this end of next week or end of this
early next.
Hopefully folks will continue to just say,
screw YouTube.
I'm going to support you directly through
membership and Patrion and I'll update you
when I have more information.
Really ugly stuff that's going on.